Salut, mes petits poulets !
Non, je ne suis pas en train de craquer...
Enfin si un petit peu mais ça n'a rien à voir.
C'est par rapport à l'énigme d'hier que je vous appelle mes petits poulets.
Puisque hier on parlait de poules
et qu'avant de vous donner l'énigme d’aujourd’hui
je vous donne la réponse de l'énigme d'hier.
Si vous l'avez pas vu, regardez là avant d'écouter la réponse !
Donc, combien d’œufs vont pondre 400 poules en 4 jours ?
Réponse = 200
Puisque 800 poules pondent 800 œufs en 8 jours.
Ça veut dire que 800 poules pondent 100 œufs en 1 jours !
Donc 2 fois moins de poules en une journée vont pondre 2 fois moins d’œufs = 50
Et donc en 4 fois plus de temps, 4 jours, 4*50 = 200
Elle était pas hyper compliqué
Je regarderais le ratio de pouce en l'air pour voir combien d'entre vous avait trouvé la bonne réponse.
Par contre l'énigme d'aujourd'hui, elle est plus coton
mais alors pour moi c'est la plus intéressante.
Énigme 20, énigme compliqué je vous le dis direct !
Vous arrivez au purgatoire !
Ah oui alors désolé, je vous ai pas précisé vous êtes mort...
Pour cette énigme !
Vous arrivez au purgatoire et là devant vous il y a 2 personnes
identique en tous points, même visage, même tenu.
Il n'y a pas un détail qui les différencie, même pas dans la voix, rien !
Derrière chacune de ces 2 personnes, il y a une porte.
Pour toute les deux identique, il y a rien qui les différencie, rien !
Mais vous, vous avez un parchemin sur lequel il est écrit:
L'un des deux est dieu, il est devant la porte du paradis et dit toujours la vérité systématiquement !
L'autre est le diable, il est devant la porte de l'enfer et il ment tout le temps quoi qu'il arrive, il ment !
Vous avez le droit de poser une seule question !
À un des deux uniquement !
Et sa réponse devra vous permettre de choisir la porte du paradis.
Sauf si vous préférez aller en enfer...
Mais ça, c'est votre choix.
En tout cas, en posant une seule question à l'un des deux
vous devrez être en mesure de déterminer quel est la porte du paradis et la porte de l'enfer.
Je vous conseil de faire un petit schéma quand même sur un papier pour essayer de résoudre cette énigme.
Elle est très compliqué !
C'est mon prof de math qui me l'a fais quand j'étais en 1ere.
J'ai passé 1 ou 2 jours dessus, j'ai pas trouvé la solution...
Je vous le dis pour vous rassurer sur le fait quelle soit pas évidente.
Par contre, c'est très intéressant de chercher
ça vous permettra encore mieux d'apprécier la réponse derrière.
Si jamais vous trouvez la solution
ne la dites pas dans les commentaires, ce serait trop dommage !
Par contre, vous pouvez me le faire savoir en laissant un petit pouce en l'air
comme ça on verra le nombre de pouce en l'air et donc le nombre de personnes qu'ont trouvé la réponse.
Profitez bien du soleil ! Passez un bel été
Rendez vous demain à 17h !
Ciao !